okay thank you very much for the
invitation so yes let's start right away
basically I'm gonna be talking a little
bit about the non-competitive setting
and then some things a bit different
afterwards but the the main question
comes from the results that we have on
algebric branching programs and this is
mainly the this really beautiful result
from Nissan which gets an exact
characterization of the complexity for
non commutative algebra granting
programs and there's been some work in
non commutative computation over the
years this is obviously not an
exhaustive list afterwards I just
mentioned this because for me it was
always a kind of a surprise that this
extremely simple result did not have
that many extensions for a while and
that's why we always quite happy to be
able to get some different kinds of
extensions and generalization and this
especially the the last one also gave an
extension of the characterization so
some stronger types of models where we
can pinpoint exactly the complexity you
give me a polynomial I look at some
ranks some objects on matrix and I say
ok the smallest size of the whatever
model computing it is this exactly and
what I want to talk about today is not
something that I'm involved in but it is
the fact that recently some colleagues
in in Paris they show how you can get
these results
from the results on formal series so in
a way it's interesting to see that even
Neeson's results goes back much further
it's there's a much older result that
basically gives everything and then that
you have an extension of these older
results to formal series that are not on
words but on trees and these with some
work and that's what they do here is the
work we'll give you basically what we
had there so it's kind of nice what I
will not do is actually talk about what
they do but I want to do is
really go back to the old results which
have more algebraic flavor and
presentation because if you go look at
their so it's on archive I think or
which about the preprint servers they
too because they address an algebraic
complexity audience they write it again
in the language of circuits and stuff
like that but I want to do the
presentation in the original language
with keys where the flavor is more
algebraic so just to start I'm sure
everybody knows what NAB P is and
Nissan's result but just very quickly so
you have this layered graph you have
linear combinations on the of the
variables and the edges the weight of
the path is a product and then you sum
the weights of all the paths and this
gives you your compression model and in
this ins case you have a nice layered
ABP because you're only interested in
computing homogeneous polynomials and
we'll come back to that
what is Nissan's result well he says ok
I'm going to cut my position it's not
commutative and it's a modulus of the
greedy so I can really see monomials
with positions and I'm going to cut
position that said position K right all
the possible monomials of degree K all
possible monomials of degree D minus K
and in in this matrix I'll put the
coefficient of the polynomial I'm
interested in so I have a line for every
monomial of the greek'
column for every monomial degree D minus
K and then I look at the rank of this
matrix and it gives me some kind of
complexity measure and then if I sum
actually all the ranks of these matrices
then I get the size of the smallest
homogeneous algebraic branching programs
for my polynomial so I get my exact
characterization and obviously then if
you do a short computation for the
permanent then you can get it all about
incidentally that was we were talking
about this yesterday if you do this for
the determinant we had said it was not
clear that you had some non-trivial
community in our computation of the of
the determinant but the same computation
Nissen gives you an algorithm for the
for the determine
with the same firmness and paper with no
computation it's a characterization yeah
so you actually get you you really get
the same exact computation okay so we
switch and we go to formal series
onwards so why do we let okay so I'm
gonna I'm gonna use a book by a burst or
in return hour as my basis for further
talk and if you use the book it's things
are more complicated the way I'm going
to show them because they do things more
generally so instead of working over a
field they'll work over semi ring or
something like that so things get kind
of hairy but we'll stay with the field
so everything is really extremely simple
actually so you fix the field and you
have a finite alphabet and you look at
finite words and a formal series is just
a function from the form from the finite
words to your field and I'll use the
usual notation in this in this domain
actually wikipedia says that this is a
idiosyncratic I don't know why but
that's the way it's written so the
coefficient of a given word in the
series is not this way so you can
rewrite the series in this way and
there's this notation for the set of
formal series it's easy to define the
support and if you have fun I suppose
you call these polynomials and you get
the set of non commutative polynomials
because your words are inherently non
commutative objects if you
and now we'll isolate a certain subset
of the formal series that we call
recognizable and for this we'll say that
we have a linear representation and what
it is will lead some dimension some
integer so we'll be actually so here
it's the matrices but basically it's
kind of like you know why were over K to
the end so the vector space so we have a
finite dimensional vector space you
could have written it this way and you
have a morphism you know it's from the
words to the set of matrices and two
extra okay vectors line and n : and what
you want for it to represent a certain
formal series is that the coefficient of
a word is expressed as this so this is a
matrix product so you have a line matrix
column and then it gives you just the
coefficient and obviously to define a
more face of Monowitz you you just need
to define mu over all the letters in
your alphabet and then by the monoid
property the morpheus property it
extends to all finite words okay so this
is called a linear representation and is
a dimension and it is maybe not
obviously but it is an automaton so
maybe I should nevertheless make a small
drawing basically what are you saying
you are saying that you look at the
words and this as an extension of your
mu H each Muir gives you some kind of
matrix and so you have let's say 1 2 n
which are the states of your automaton
and for a given letter a you have some
coefficient so let's say mu a IG that
says you can go from I to J and if you
put them all and write them like this
and then you add an extra 2 extras this
is input and this is output and this
will be the lung does okay along the eye
and this will be the MU
you can I thank you I was thinking Mew
is not a good idea it's the other
notation okay
then basically the as an automaton the
coefficient of a word in your series
will be the sum of all the ways of
getting the word going from input to
output so obviously what happens is that
inside here you could have loops cycles
there is no this is for formal series
support is not necessary finite so you
can have cycles in there and now we want
to characterize recognizable series so
sorry it's easy to see that you have a
vector based vector space structure and
we'll define this construction you take
a word and you look at you minus 1s and
the easiest way to say is see what it is
is that the coefficient of a certain
word in this new series is just the
coefficient in the old series of the
word u-w okay in other words you take
everything in s that starts with you
everything else you throw it away
you take everything that starts with you
you factorize you and what you have in
your parentheses is your new you - 1 x +
a sub set of formal series will be
called stable well if when I use this
operation I stay there now you have this
3 really ok so I put these names here
it's not completely clear that the
history is this way but with my
presentation so I wanted to quote them
because it's the oldest result that kind
of implied this but it's not completely
clear the linear history but formal
series is recognizable if there is a
finite dimensional linear subspace that
is stables and contains my formal series
okay so what I want to do even though I
don't have a lot of time I want to I
want to give a proof of this and it's
not because the proof is really
illuminating it's more because it's but
yes why isn't the more space Leonel
space which contains SMS available for
more series everything yes but it's not
finite okay so it's not that the proof
is particularly illuminating I think but
I think it's particularly simple and I
want to stress this anyway if you're at
least if you stay what you ever feel
this proof is very simple so I will do
it not too slowly because I want to talk
about other things but I want to show
this so there's two ways you you want to
say if it's recognizable then I get this
linear subspace if I have the rest of
space then it's recognizable so suppose
you have it's recognizable so you have a
linear representation then you start by
defining the your generator set that you
want for your finite dimensional stable
subset that contains s and it'll just be
defined in this way so that it's clear
that s is a linear combination you
remember s had the coefficient of a word
for s had to be given by this matrix
product and you can just slice it by
index and it gives you that it's a
linear combination of the si that you've
defined here basically so this you get
it for the containment the finite
dimension equals is because you've
defined just a finite number of them and
the stability is just a computation that
is only realized on the more FISMA
basically okay so I'll just skip it you
can do it and the other ways may be just
a little bit it takes just a little bit
more time but suppose that you have such
a finite dimensional sub set that
contains s and that is stable so you say
that it's generated by some form of
syriza's twice s 1 to s n and then what
you want to do is define those
this mu the small face of Manu is over
all the letters of your finite alphabet
and you'll do this by saying okay if I
take this series for one of my
generators I know that it's in my set M
therefore it is itself a linear
combinations of my generators and I use
this to define my coefficients basically
I will call this this alpha J forget
them now I just call them U a IJ and
this defines my my matrices I needed and
then there's a small computation where I
think here there's on the side but I
have no idea very similar to eliminate
in division from computation of a
polynomial then you cut it by the degree
of the output it's also a very classical
thing in automata theory that you look
at the questions of that you can create
and that gives you basically the sets
the states of some other matter knows
things like that when you have a
language okay so there's a computation
that I will skip but everything works ok
so just with this small result you can
see that also there's a kind of tight
relationship between the dimension of
your presentation and dimension of the
linear subspace and just for example
even though that's actually the so there
is this name anyway
yes here so there's this lemma and it's
proved the same way in a way by affinity
because they look
the rank of with this ants result
basically but here it's it's an old
theorem also and it's completely obvious
if you have generators for s and T then
if you look at the atom a product and
Ivan will talk about it also tomorrow I
think which is defined as just taking
the product of the coefficient
coefficient by coefficient then if you
have recognizable series then also the
atom a product and if you apply this you
have I haven't talked about polynomials
yet finite support singular but if you
apply it if you believe me and it works
for polynomials and finite support then
you just get this and at this level it's
completely clear that's why I kind of
like it at this algebraic level so now
yes okay we were talking about formal
series but what happens for for for okay
not yet
okay now the previous result actually
it's in a way you say okay if there
exists this subset that sleep okay so
why not look at the smallest one which
means why not look at everything that's
generated by these series basically and
then if you do that you can start to see
what's happening in your basically in
essence matrices and what will be called
the Henkel matrices you look at the
dimension of the space generated by
these guys and you get that this
dimension is the smallest dimension if
it's finite of a linear representation
size of a small so smartin and this is
what is called the Henkel matrix so
before in a way you were saying okay if
I have U and V and I put the coefficient
of fi UV and I get my matrix and it
means that this line is just u minus 1s
this quotient and when I look at the
rank of this matrix I'm just really
looking at the rank of this minimal
stable sub linear subset that contains
the s okay
so now if you go back to a bps that's
what I was thinking up you have an exact
characterization of complexity if you
just use your tomatoes as a
computational model and the problem is
that there may be cycles and they have
an observation that if the polynomial is
homogeneous then a minimal automaton is
an ABP actually the derp here is not I
mean I wanted to write and that's on the
next slide actually I think any minimal
tomato that you get from the Henkel
matrix will actually be actually be I
see a psychic it doesn't matter on the
choice that you no choice you make this
can be seen maybe I'll skip this this
can be seen because of the way you
define your matrix but I'll skip this it
can be seen better here is that
basically you'll be expressing certain
polynomials of a certain degree as
linear combinations of other polynomials
of degrees that can be of different
degrees but since you have a kind of
block matrix if you polynomials
homogeneous you cannot complete complete
some monomial with something that is too
small or too big
etc okay so what about non homogeneous
polynomials so what I just said is that
if it's homogeneous all minimal to
myself in from the Heinkel matrix are
ATP's they are cyclic so what is your
intuition if I give you a non
homogeneous polynomial do you think that
having loops in the MVP can it help you
compute it faster or not I see oh no so
yes this is true but it's not true that
all minimal automata will be a cyclic so
this is a little thing that I can add
for you
for the talk today but first we have a
small challenge give me the smallest ABP
you can find for this polynomial
all right here what can I do I can do
this hey a plus B and it's true that I
won't be able to find smaller with loops
but can you find one that has the same
size with loops I said not all Minamoto
Matins can use loops can you compute
this very simple polynomial with loops
and you can check that if you do this so
I hope I won't make a mistake
- B and this is output and this is input
then it computes the same thing
so can we always have one that is region
a BP well okay so this is something that
actually you can do it's not very very
hard to see there exist a minimal time a
time defined from the matrix which is a
cyclic and then it means you get a
slight generalization of distance result
in general the VP complexity of a
polynomial is the rank of the Hinkle
matrix whether it be homogeneous or not
so it won't be exactly the same kind of
a layered IBPS as in this sense where
they arose go just from one level to the
other patil B we don't have a shape that
is similar okay so I'm going to go very
fast for the the rest of the of the of
the talk but the rest of the talk has no
no technical details so now let's look
at formal series on trees I will stay in
the general more algebraic setting and
this means that now I have a finite
ranked alphabet means I have symbol with
era T's so Sigma is a union of Sigma K
and Sigma K is a symbol that will take K
arguments if you want so Sigma 0 is my
letters
the my a from last time and now you
consider trees over Sigma that means
that if I have a I didn't write it here
but if you as usual when define trees
the tree is either an element of Sigma 0
it's obtained by you're applying a
symbol of rit k to k trees that i've
already obtained okay and this gives us
as my undergrad teacher would call it
the free magma over Sigma but I think
this is a French terminology yeah it
goes well with solar methods and the
galactica so I think it's really French
i but we really thought this way I don't
know why and the formal series is just a
function from trees just think trees
over my ear alphabet
okay you have all the same definition
and polynomials with these weird symbols
objects okay and now you will get also a
notion of a recognizability
and also we have some mapping but it
gets a little bit so you for each people
you need some K linear map so it's I
will go quickly it's the point is not so
much of a region understanding what
happens and you also can characterize
with it's in a way the same kind of
result form or series that are
recognizable so these are really formal
series of a trees so what does it tell
us for us what is interesting ok yeah
this I will skip you also have an idea
of a Hinkle matrix with context I will
skip basically all this let's just look
at the case where you only have
variables Sigma 0 and then you have just
one symbol of RIT to so you are really
looking at binary trees over your
variable so you are looking at monomials
that are non commutative and
non-associative ok and so your formal
series are non committed in a series and
if the support is finite you are looking
at point-o mules but you are now in the
case where they are non associative non
commutative and then you get everything
else so this is also what they notice is
that basically in that case the
automaton can be seen as circuits if
they are cyclic and you get the same
kind of characterization so which means
that you get again the fact that you
perfectly understand the complexity of
computing non-associative non
commutative polymer which in a way is
not we should surprise I'm telling you
you're computing this polynomial and
each monomial I tell you exactly the
computation structure in the way the
associative structure and then it's not
a surprise but it's not obvious based on
the surprise well then you can say
exactly what is the smallest way to get
this ok so again it's possible to see
that in the case of non homogeneous
polynomials they will not always all not
all minimal automata that you get from
the Henkel matrix are cyclic but there
will be your choice of minimal automata
that which is a cyclic which will give
you a circuit in this case
this I will skip to so I just want to
get to this conclusion so we understand
perfectly what happens for an
associative non-committed phone also one
question could be can I use this okay I
want to show lower bounds for you know
the open question we don't have better
lower bounds for general non creative
secrets than the just general lower
bounds for circuits so can I use this to
get lower bounds for non commutative
circuits what would I need to do
basically any non commutative
computation I can see it as being non
associated I can write the Hinkel matrix
I can look at it but I'm not replacing I
don't get a good measure I'm not
replacing my quest for lower bound with
a measure that says okay now I don't
have to think about to show that there
doesn't exist small circuits or whatever
here you are going from those edges to
small circuit to does there exist some
way of writing the Hinkle mate research
that eyes when I identify
non-associative monomials and project
them down to their associative version
it gives you the polynomial I'm
interested in so they still this kind of
it exists you are still such space over
possible expression of your Hankel
matrix of a given module so it's not
clear that it helps really a lot but
it's still some way of looking at it
basically you get that you have to some
linear constraints on the coefficient of
a matrix and you want to lower bound the
rank of a matrix and there's something
there conflicts that you can write
explicitly but that still does not help
you I mean at least for the moment one
other reason why this might not be a
fruitful angle of attack for this
problem is that actually they also
notice something very fun but is that
actually you can take away the
non-competitive part so you also get an
exact translation of psychology for just
for non associativity this is very
strange but it actually completely works
it's not I can do a lot of things that
make it work now it's exactly you just
define your trees as unordered instead
of order and the whole process works
exactly the same there is no no
difference okay so this means that if
you can do something too clever here and
it might be possible to do it here and
then I mean
I mean they it's not gonna work but then
you get general or bouncing I don't
think it's gonna be with this more ankle
metrics things that you're gonna get
lower bounds for general circuit so okay
I think I'm going to stop there
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry that's a very good question so
it's hard to get something for I would
like to have a characterization for
formulas it's difficult because you see
that this is it's what I said it's
basically say just you get your
information only from the structure the
necessary structure of your monomials
and the formula is something that is
just about the computational model but
doesn't change the I mean it will give
you some things on the on the way you
build your monomials but you if you take
a secret and you spread it as a formula
it will give the same associative
structure so it's hard to find you could
also say okay I'm gonna look at Hankel
matrices where what I write in the
matrix
I skipped everything so it's not here
but I only I know that I can paralyze
them for example so maybe I will look at
income matrices where I restrict the the
trees that I write to be overlock depth
but this will not help you separate from
branching programs because ranching
program can also be paralyzed so I would
like a characterization of formula size
in this context that's something I would
really like
[Applause]